there's a mind set out there that
because they are in the public eye that
really the public owns part of them and
that we have that right to you know read
about them and comment about them on
yahoo and do whatever what do you say to
that i still feel like they're human
beings but some people think that we own
them sometimes you chose this life so
you have to deal with it someone
actually told me that when they saw
face-to-face they said I don't think you
understand that the public now pretty
much owns face-to-face because it's such
a universal topic you know a social
media and and feeling isolated and using
social media as a way to connect and you
know it's um I don't know I totally lost
frame of where we were going with that
was a question again um in terms of like
even but that's actually perfect because
with social media now too we've all oh
the owning the public owning the public
yeah I mean I think that in a way the
public does have a right to the lives of
people that make themselves public
figures and share themselves publicly
but there's got to be respect there
because they're human beings you know I
mean they go through everything that any
person goes through and there needs to
be dignity and respect given to other
human beings no matter how famous they
are well that being said to now with
social media we can put our lives out
there and possibly co-workers so we may
not really
friends with can see us and is that okay
for them to be included in what we're
doing I mean is there as there are
boundaries like sort of a line you know
in terms of like you feel like you know
someone because maybe they're friends
with you on facebook but I mean how much
do we really know people and where's
that boundary being drawn or do we give
that boundary away by sharing our stuff
on Facebook I think you lose a lot of
your personal life when you put it out
on the internet and you're you're
consciously choosing to do that to share
that so then it becomes sort of anyone
who's out there for the taking and
you've got to set that boundary for
yourself well you know I did a two month
Facebook cleanse where i deactivated my
account and I'm like I'm not going on
social media for two months it was the
best two months of my life least amount
of drama I've ever had in my life now I
limit it to like 30 minutes a day but
once you're out there you're out there
you know and what you put out there is
going to spread
you